Cyril majorerais déjà dire une chose
c'est ce qui est inadmissible ce sont
les commentaires du garde des sceaux en
ce qui me concerne moi je considère
qu'il est il a commis un manquement à
son devoir de réserve à son et il a pas
de commentaires à faire surtout que vous
avez réagi de façon spontanée exactement
en tant que père de famille devant
l'horreur alors ça c'est quelque chose
d'humain et l'injustice est-ce qu'on est
encore dans le domaine de l'humain je
sais qu'elle s'est déshumanise à fond
puisque on va traiter les procédures
avec des ordinateurs maintenant elle a
pu l'habitude on a plus de contact avec
les victimes ou avec les gens qui
ressemblent comme vous mais les Français
ont bien compris votre réaction ce qui
est inadmissible comme vous le dites
c'est qu'il passe son temps sur les
plateaux à faire des commentaires et je
pense pas qu'il soit le mieux placé
parce que c'est quand même un délinquant
disons les choses comme il est mieux un
examen dans une affaire de trafic
d'influence pour des pressions exercées
sur des magistrats au pôle financier et
mon avis il est mal placé pour faire des
commentaires sur
ce que vous avez déclaré spontanément
dans l'émotion et c'est ça qui est
inadmissible pour moi alors qui reste
dans son dans son ministère il je pense
qu'il est très occupé il a beaucoup de
choses à faire et puis c'est tout quand
il était avocat il passait son temps
critiquer à taper sur les magistrats
alors un peu de retenue monsieur le
garde des siens magistrat c'est un très
grand magistrat qui a été avec une
source pour ça que je voulais qu'il soit
là aussi Claude pour donner son
éclairage là dessus aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que vous avez tout résumé moi j'ai
parlé en paire de famille et je vous dis
les Français ont tous réagi comme moi en
grand frère en paix en père en
grand-père en cousin
c'était la cousine la sœur la petite
sœur là la fille de tous les Français
Eric Dupont-Moretti moi je n'ai pas vu
une once
de
toucher
il vient sur une émission après un drame
pareil 0 empathie alors je l'ai invité
qui viennent ici hein ce qu'il dit voilà
c'est un grand instant un grand avocat
il va être courageux donc qui viennent
ici qui viennent en parler avec moi ça
fait des semaines et des semaines que je
l'invite sur plusieurs sujets il ne
vient jamais donc Eric Dupond-Moretti on
vous attend mais aller sur un plateau de
télé pour faire un buzz pareil et je
vous le dis la question
il a voulu qu'on lui pose cette question
Gilles tu as les infos il a voulu qu'on
lui pose Kelly avec Lemoine lui pose
cette question vous étiez spontané salut
et d'ailleurs on le voit dans la
question il dit ah vous voulez parler de
Monsieur Hanouna comme si il attendait
de la part de la présentatrice qui
d'ailleurs ne répond pas après est un
peu gêné oui il voulait se payer Cyril
Hanouna moi j'ai trouvé ça grave
diffamatoire presque injurieux je ne
comprends pas il est sorti totalement de
son rôle de son devoir de réserve j'ai
trouvé un ministre de la Justice sur les
nerfs fragilisés et pas du tout à la
hauteur de la situation et du drame
effectivement sans aucune émotion c'est
pas ce ne sont pas des paroles digne
d'un ministre de la Justice comme tous
les citoyens français on a le droit à la
liberté d'expression et tous ceux qui
ont fait qui ont fait et qui ont fait
des éditaux là-dessus donc Sofia Aram
sur France Inter je vous le dis ça il
faut que ça soit vraiment examiné par la
com parce que rigoler là-dessus et
insulter m'insulter dans sa chronique
c'est extrêmement grave
qu'elle soit pas drôle sans le savais
mais qu'elle soit hors-la-loi ça
maintenant on le sait et endroit quand
même la liberté d'expression et les
garanties par notre Constitution article
100 depuis la Révolution à 89 c'est
écrit dans la loi la liberté
d'expression à partir du moment où vous
n'avez pas été injurieux vous n'avez pas
un trajet vous n'avez pas insulté vous
avez exprimé un sentiment quelque chose
de naturel devant ce drame c'est vrai
que c'est un drame donc il y a pas de
commentaires à faire je veux dire
alors Steve Ruben maître vous avez fait
un Twitter est-ce qu'on peut voir le
tweet de type s'il vous plaît merci
voilà ils vont ils vont le mettre ils
sont en train de le retrouver mais c'est
vrai que vous vous avez dit que c'est
juste et vous m'avez fait peur en
faisant ce tweet que vous allez voir ce
qu'il dit il a dit c'est juste qu'on est
un peu en avance sur les autres sur une
sur une justice comme celle que je
devrais être un peu en je vous ai
apporté un peu la contradiction si vous
voulez très bien oui d'abord
si ce que vous avez dit mardi ou
mercredi c'est assisté au temps
d'émotions et donc l'intervention du
garder ça c'est quelque part ça a
dérangé cette notion de justice un peu
expéditive elle est pas nouvelle
figurez-vous j'ai fait des quelques
recherches en 76 déjà lorsqu'il y a eu
une affaire qui était relative à Patrick
Henry il y avait un journaliste Gicquel
et Roger Gicquel qui a vivre exactement
on paye le même terme une justice
expédiative de pas tomber dans ses
travers là
tout est décisions qui sont rendus
maintenant je voudrais juste vous
répondre sur un point vous vous pensez
peut-être et je le dis très humblement
vous pensez à tort qui est un procès
dans deux semaines trois semaines un
mois ça pourrait apaiser des choses en
fait pas du tout imaginez un petit peu
parce que le procès pénal de l'auteur
c'est aussi le procès de la victime
c'est à dire que elle a sa place elle a
le droit d'avoir un avocat elle a droit
de voir le dossier à droite d'apporter
la contradiction alors d'apporter des
éléments et au contraire c'est un moment
de débat et j'ai eu là par exemple la
semaine dernière
moi je pense que un procès qui dure des
mois et des mois pour la famille c'est
insupportable et puis pour je vous dis
le problème qu'on a c'est l'oubli et
chaque drame le gros problème qu'on a
sur chagrin c'est qu'après on oublie et
qu'après ça recommence et qu'on a
toujours les gens qui viennent sur les
plateaux dire oui ça doit plus se
reproduire et ça et je vous dis ça mais
Français n'en veulent plus on a ce tout
lit parce que la justice n'est plus
adaptée on le voit aujourd'hui tout est
instantané c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on
veut de la formation immédiate est-ce
que franchement vous avez déjà reçu ici
un procureur de la République ou un
magistrat qui vient vous donner un
éclairage sur un dossier la seule
audience qui était publique dans ce
dossier c'était son passage devant un
juge quel juge des libertés et la
détention ou la presse effectivement
pourrait être représentant pour apporter
des éléments de réponse objectif et ça
vous l'avez compris ça a été totalement
refusé moi jaune moi je voudrais vous
dire toute façon on est jamais on est
toujours mécontent d'une décision de
justice c'est malheureux à dire mais
c'est cette famille c'est cette mère que
j'ai entendu avec des sangles dans la
voix ça va durer comme vous dites ça va
durer des mois elle va vivre ça bien son
pas très dur je veux dire et puis en fin
de compte la justice a pourra pas la
soulager on n'est jamais satisfait d'une
décision de justice il y a l'aléah
judiciaire qui fait qu'ils vont bien
s'abstenir bon là on peut pas faire
autrement il va falloir aller quand même
à l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est quoi
passer aussi pour du bon muretti de
faire des réformes qui s'imposent un
projet un projet d'ailleurs il a plagié
mon livre un projet sur faut redonner
confiance aux l'institution judiciaire
moi j'avais écrit mon livre avant vous
avez confiance à la justice vous êtes
déjà venu ici une fois je suis venu des
problèmes d'ailleurs après d'ailleurs je
suis moi-même poursuivi parce que par la
hiérarchie si ça parle la roquette de
Dupond-Moretti et j'étais entendu
j'étais auditionné il y a 15 jours par
le magistrat rapporteur j'ai répondu
calmement et cetera en disant que
c'était un livre c'était mon vécu
c'était ni un essai c'était ni une étude
ni un traité sur la justice c'était mon
expérience à moi vu l'intérieur il faut
que les gens sachent comment les choses
se passent quels sont les moyens qu'on a
vous savez qu'on a actuellement
9241 magistrat sous la pôle emploi en
1848 il y en avait eu
8400 donc il y a des pratiquement le
même nombre alors on fait appel à des
des magistrats à la retraite à des des
gens sous contraste on essaie de
bricoler mais il faut une vraie volonté
politique pour changer et puis le statut
on parle d'indépendance mais le statut
de la justice c'est un véritable carcan
pour les juges les juges sont notés ils
sont évalués maintenant touche des
primes modulables qui sont à la
discrétion de leur hiérarchie etc on
parle d'indépendance mais allez-y
carrément alors couper le cordon
ombilical avec le pouvoir parce que
Dupont-Moretti quoi c'est un homme
politique mais il fait partie du
gourmand du gouvernement et dans votre
histoire d'un endroit de Raphaël on a
l'impression qu'il se considère comme un
procureur en disant voilà il donne son
avis mais quoi il représente le CSA il
représente quoi il représente que
lui-même alors qui reste dans dans son
bureau place Vendôme qu'il aille de
temps en temps faire des visites dans
les prisons ou autre mais qui viennent
pas sur les plateaux faire son grand
numéro parce qu'en plus je suis pas sûr
qu'il est convaincu parce qu'il a dit
alors justement monsieur Dupont-Moretti
j'espère que vous allez venir nous voir
prochainement ça serait bien qu'ils
viennent nous voir pour en discuter et
surtout n'oubliez pas c'est du pont
morétique moi j'ai parlé en tant que
père de famille comme beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui se sont exprimés sur les
réseaux ou autre
et j'ai parlé avec le coeur on aimerait
bien que vous parliez un peu plus avec
le coeur monsieur Dupont-Moretti aussi